ok oh mein gott oh mein gott es wird
einfach alles zusammen geile habrock
farbe seiner träume zerstören
ob ich auch nicht höher mit einem
jetpack hey leute und herzlich
willkommen zu einer erkältet folge
zusammen mit komme und zwar bin ich
übelst krank ich habe eine nacht mit
offenem fenster geschlafen und dachte
hey cool frische luft in letzter zeit
zum einen dass auch ich glaube sie ist
auch in der fei scams meinen augen
einfach übels rot sind
das kommt von der erkältung und mit der
weise komme hallo erstmal natürlich
endlich gute besserung jetzt auch der
gute besserung wollen sagt er würde
zieht sich da irgendwas rein und
soziales arschloch oder meine aufnahmen
gehört also damit grad am arsch der welt
welche letzten erfolge meine crawley
gesucht habe ich gibt es gerade mal auf
denn wir beide wollen hier in der stadt
etwas machen
ja wir haben uns nämlich gedacht also
dass wir etwas soziales hier machen
werden wieso steht hier eigentlich so
einen baum
stock du stinkst wo ich komme hier nicht
raus thema auf das grundstück mittel von
rotwild alter turner explosion ist eine
explosion
simon ja das ist
ich hab's geschafft
zum glück haben wir eine öffentliche
ladestation da werde ich mich erstmal
mit dem alter ist dass laut hier ja die
explosion war simon
es ist unglaublich raum alter ich bin
aus den fehlern
ich wollte gerade den sound leiser
machen ich stelle es mir die ränder
distance tor unter sparpakt einfach
überall sachen reinalter warum macht er
das
jetzt der kuchen war von peace von coly
und dem wissen dass angriffe auf essen
darüber habe ich schon mal mit ihm
gesprochen und alter wusste die
solarpanels nie für solarpanels
also ich möchte mal eben schon was da
eben gerade bei ihm hoch gegangen ist
bei uns gespielt vielleicht irgendwie
ein überschuss von julio meter kann doch
sein was ja ist aber ich höre dich nicht
mehr wenn ich da hin fliegen manchmal
ganz den ton aus dem minecraft achter
castillo meter ja ich war aber hoch
ehrlich da mal rein
jetzt klappt wie mal helfen finde ich
finde wenn man schon mal sozial tätig
wird dann sollte man das ja wir wollen
nämlich sehr soziale sache machen wie
zum beispiel stadt erweitern uns das
alles wollen wir sie mal eine goldküste
bauen und die noch daran stellen wer
genau das machen soll ich eben einen
baum
komm wir machen team kommen wir machen
die mein gott was machst du das eben
dann tatsächlich er hat aber ich
verstehe es auch nicht ich hätte auch
keine lust mehr auf megaprojekt wenn ich
so viel juli meter hätte einfach mal
damit kann man sich irgendwie alles
entschied mittlerweile oder wenn ich sie
mal würde ich mir aus dem jupiter ganz
ganz viele diamant blöcke machen geben
so ein haus aus diamanten bauen einfach
man muss das nicht unbedingt wahrnehmen
ist ja immer so eine sache
aber wenn du selbst wenn du weißt dass
du dir einfach alles bieten kannst dann
fällt es ihm auch ein bisschen
langweilig natürlich ehrt halt viel
schon geschafft er sprach ich dachte
fest dass das trampolin lass mir bitte
bauen warte ich stelle mich jetzt hier
hin da bekommst du dich hier auf der
werkbank bekommst du mich niemals
kannst du mir ist in gold hole aus einer
tour den ton wieder anmachen fällt mir
da draußen
grund genug die explosion des übels laut
alter mache ich denn gold mit you make
up gold ich habe gold fast schon ich
will doch nichts von simon nehmen
deswegen wollen wir wenn wir über
irgendwas sprechen während wir hier so
ein bisschen die stadt verschönern oder
etwas was machst du denn überhaupt
gerade ich mache gerade die diamanten
schätzt herr kollege acht euro für den
simon del
was hat ein team hier wieder gibt die
skistars der hat er sogar wille da drin
deshalb schenken kirche darstellen das
egal wo bist du gerade beim thema auf
dem grundstück das der mégane eis so ich
habe einen diamanten truhe erstmal hier
schnell gemacht so da muss ich mal eben
die flutung renten sodann wie man sich
das mal so richtig viele diamanten
unnötig denn hier schon wieder gebaut
alter ist voll
als ob das ist doch direkt vor meiner
nase direkt beim leben
die diamanten ist komplett voll junge
ist es der rest ist auch wieder voll
mithelfen liegt auch mehr gute etwas
soziales machen anstatt darin können wir
gerne machen ja da wollen wir ihnen
einen weg bauen oder wir können den weg
auf jeden fall noch mal erweitert damit
gerade hier bei deinem kunststück das er
noch gewählt
da kann man ja dass du gegen stein
aussetzen dafür brauchen wir noch mal
koppel woher bekommen wir nun viel
koppel
das ist die frage die balance im juli
meter bekommt man kein koppeln oder was
sind das doch oder gerade weil das sind
das überhaupt für dings für steine dass
es kommisson was das andere das andere
warte dass da würde ich da einfach mal
ein abbauen und schaue wie wieder heißt
dann könnte ich das ich kenne ja auch
nicht alle blöcke ist kann ich gar nicht
aufnehmen
mein ganzes inventars voll alter ja
meint auch mit das system schüssel
stonebridge und wie macht man die
wahrscheinlich eigentlich mit einer säge
oder kann das sein
mit dem break hitler kann er sein hitler
händler jsl
woher bekommen wir kommen bricht man auf
history vier breaks in den quadraten
citrix krieg war neben den vier tonnen
quadrat tut und koppel aus juni geht das
davor doch weiterbauen
hewlett rezept ich schaue mal kurz nach
der mach mal nebenbei kurzweiligen nase
aber dann verschwindet man ganz kurz aus
dem bild hier raus wie mache ich mir
kaufe ich sage der sge
wunderschöne wunderschön so hört ihr das
leute er zieht sich schon wieder eine
leine durch die nase dieser
drogenabhängige komm ich höre ich noch
ein junger mann ich lese so fertig aus
interface kann ich hab's rote augen
heftig allerdings am liebsten dort zu
tun dass ich nehmen wir keine drogen ich
hab mir nur rat die nase geputzt
man kriegt daraus sogar 16 stone direkt
einfach ein juliane mitte recht ja das
ist der aufzug von kv daisy geil gemacht
hast du eigentlich die dia blöcke
gesehen die den und nicht gebaut haben
ja habe ich
vielen dank bitteschön so warte ich habe
jetzt mein ganzes inventar voller stolz
tags
geil bist du liebe die erde
ich bin sogar schüler im kräften wenn
ich irgendwo er das gefühl hier hier
hier so egal ich fange mal an hier mit
den ganzen arbeiten wovon ich mache hier
vorne da fehlt der weg so hier meine
ganzen krawehl ersetzen dafür euch an
wunderschönen zauberstab
er macht das alter ich bin so voll
bepackt mit jupiter das ist unglaublich
jetzt kann ich das alles hinter und soll
ich will nicht so viel wie ihre touren
sind vorn und dem schwenk macht eine
neue true ii so stone
so ich habe schon relativ viel scheiße
da okay so so so kannst du ja vielleicht
gleich setzen weil da kann ich mit dem
zauberstab nicht wirklich hinterher
kommen weil man die die als partner
glaube ich neben den weg gesetzt
es ist recht okay da müsstest du also
ich hab jetzt unruhig haben jetzt 10 6
von diesem schüssel stone briggs wieder
dicht daran teil durch alte x 10.6
ergibt ja wo ich auch noch mal eng keine
ahnung 2 steckt ab da mache ich damit
auch an weil ich bin kenne mich bei dir
wir sind am so sozial wir können ja
vielleicht zum abschluss von dem ganzen
hier von der folge ein video offen
abschluss der zweiten folge bei dir
vielleicht noch ein kleines battle
machen so wie du auch schon mitgemacht
hast aber einfach mal nur mit eisen
schwerte also weißt du mal ein ganz
normales
ich kann mich zurzeit gar nicht
konzentrieren wolle mit den hier bob
weiter machen wie man das gönn dir ne
schaufel und dann los geht's ja ich bin
dabei aber wie wollen wir das denn hier
weitermachen das ist alles so kreuz und
quer durcheinander scheiße aus ja egal
uns fällt schon was ein erwarte hierzu
rum so und ich muss mir noch mal ein
paar steine holen an alle die jetzt mehr
voll mitkommen wollen oder so ich kann
jetzt auch nicht so lange aufnehmen weil
wegen kräftiger rom bevor mit gymboree
manager dienst am 1
regine so ein spagat geht da habe ich
gesehen ich bei ihm wert gedacht
wirklich dass ich was ich weil er hat er
sich bei mir gerecht weil er dachte ich
hätte sein haus und obsidian verwandelt
und ich hätte bei ihm im haus essentials
aufgestellt aber das war ja nicht weit
da hier ein halbes haus zerstört na ja
nicht ganz so schnell da unten ich kacke
gemacht hat da schon war schon frech
verliehen
da musste ich auch frech werden ja oft
daraus erhalte ich steine hast du steine
wenn ich konnte ja ich steine durch die
mitte legen
du brauchst ja auch steine du aber
natürlich hast du brauchst cobblestone
da tust du die steine halte mails rater
oder geht es auch das geht ich glaube
das geht gar nicht es gar nicht ich
probier's mal eben schon aus the way to
expect a face raiders aber der bekommt
keinen strom
das ist komisch dass hier so alles
zubauen und weil das ja einfach so ist
scheiße verläuft zwar kann echt nur die
einfachen sachen gebaut nur so zu seinem
grundstück sowieso nix ist ja egal dann
versuchen wir hier jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen weiß bescheid
ich komme gleich mal zu dir ich mache
den brocken kommt die steine werden in
engers umgewandelt
mal schauen ob das wirklich welche kabel
wird es wird ewigkeiten dauern wenn man
sich koppel machen würde
hast du recht ob das wir zusammen ich
glaube dass wir zusammengehören moment
die cobblestone was bei hrt nicht mehr
stemmbar in den mega projekten und er
hat hier jemand ein gekoppelt und übrig
sein wird er wohl kombination übrig
haben oder ich mache dann richtig
richtig schön weg von mir zu simon okay
so genau hier rüber ich bin so ein
tiefes loch eingefallen alter bord
wieder zu wirklicher rausgekommen alter
wie krass warte warte ich bin hier bei
dir gerade auf einmal ist das milliarden
blöcke tiefes loch das war locker bin
schon wieder total
nein ohne witz gebe ja das ist total
tief damit locker milliarden nicht sogar
trill boden boden vertrieben
was machst du hier ich mache weg von mir
zu simon
aber warum man überhaupt einen neuen weg
zumindest doch auch einfach die alten
wege verschönern könnte ich aber selber
nicht was werden langweilig auch so
rasch erst als langweilig habe ich schon
zugeben ja ja hast du nie eins der
gastgeber mexiko öl soll muss sich
beweisen dass sie damit umgehen kannst
er war mal schauen
ich hole mir erst mal mit jemandem
schaufel und schaut einmal weiter macht
dass du und man wie soll ich das denn
jetzt bauen ich brauche ganz viel komik
sondern fast kein kommission mehr glaube
ich ich hab das mal alles einfach so mit
dem mini im stall umgewandelt ok oh
minimum stein könnte man daraus
eventuell koppel machen bestimmt oder
das irgendwie wird dass er wohl möglich
sei
du hast doch ganz viele kumpel aus
ausdauer schon oder ich habe kaum koppel
ich werd das doch nicht so weitertun das
dauert ewigkeiten wieso das ewigkeiten
beim meister viel zu wenig energie hat
ja dann kannst du auch bei mir machen
war der mir dauert häufig ein block e
mails red hat eine halbe sekunde pro
karte
da bin ich gleich bei dir bei mir sport
von den energie hey yo ich glaube ich
werde gleich mal ein dach fertig machen
für diese ladestation in form von der
stadt und ein paar fackeln aufstellen
das hat auch schon mal ob ich nicht erst
einmal mich um ein grundstück kümmern
soll dass ich damals vernünftigen boden
rein ziehe allerdings ist das ja die
soziale folge
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht das
lasse ich dann erstmal und dann kümmere
ich mich da einer anderen folge drum
wenn ich zum beispiel mit denen er
wieder aufnehmen wir wollten den und ich
wollte mir beim thema sprechen was wir
allerdings noch nicht sagen wollten
weil das dass ich daheim das team aber
einfach so damit reden die dann würde so
ein sch packen
du bist so einfach
hey warum das denn er hat ja dann hat er
immer wieder die schalter ausgemacht
alter
danke für den kurs
lp ich weiß noch was zu fressen jetzt
kurz herr vahl guck dir das mal an meine
fans und alles der bekommt auch strom
auch weil nacht ist leute bekommen gar
keinen strom weil nacht ist weihnacht
ist erwarten raum speichert denn keine
energie wogegen die ganze energie daraus
sind aus dem mfs in den meßstetter
wahrscheinlich so ja das kann sein oder
stoppt den messwerten bis in die usa ja
ich habe hier auch noch eine kiste also
das reicht mir schon unit ich glaube ich
ich stoppe den erstmalig in den stopp
gesorgt jedoch habe ich jetzt gestoppt
das erstmal pennen gehn dann habe ich
auch wieder strom
und ich bin mal wieder meine nase ob ich
jemals schönbett achter oben bei capcom
ich lege mich heute mal in fremde betten
ich glaube es nicht
ich liege im bett
und ich habe mir meine nase geputzt
bräuchte sie echt so fertig außer immer
wenn ich wieder so neue defense game
ryan wir denken wir sogar weißt du hast
okay mein mfs 11 uhr bekommt oder keinen
strom hat das einer zugebaut da oben
diese fuhren deswegen bekommt keinen
strom mehr wasser als zugebaut johanna
von brahms ich glaube dafür musste aber
jetzt den kompletten daher muss ich auch
was ich könnte das anders machen warte
ich habe nicht die erste sand für mich
herr mandl ich die blöcke die masse und
eine fackel in ort tricky tricky tricky
machen könnte ist dann wäre das alles
kein problem
na logo kann ich das wenn wir einen
ganzen geräte angehen würden stellen
oder
doch schon ja doch kann man nie sense
downloads das schade heroin santo cool
hat bist du hast du nicht mal irgendwann
zusammen und man aber warum kriegen die
ganze sache keinen strom
auch weil der ja ich kann keinen strom
haben weil da oben ja was drauf es
stimmt woher bekommen wir sind was ist
doof ich würde das gerne machen
sand sand sand wir kommen gar nicht dazu
hier große der stadt etwas zu machen
weil wir selber beide immer von
irgendwem betreut wollen man steht da
bern wo ich habe keine ahnung nicht aus
etwas machen aus mit einem mini
umsteigen mit etwas anderem
ich wollte könnte
frostig ein minimum stein und sense und
sandstein also dem was man aus dem
jupiter julio meter bekommt kann man
normalen sand herstellen
komm zu mir 'ich mach sandstein und du
meine mutter hat du könntest auch
einfach aus erde und einem medium
steinen sand herstellen wenn das noch so
natürlich habe auch viel erde also wenn
du brauchst sag bescheid und ein mini um
stein richtig
okay das ist cobblestone penner
nebeneinander liegen das ist komplett
orthopädie per als trainee so unfähig
oder leistet links kommt er denn und
rechts der mini um stein um stein und
aber hier wenn du mal sand eingibst aber
nach chance da steht kein gras blog ist
das okay na gut dann machen wir es über
den juli meter weg also wenn du brauchst
du hast ja genug
man sagt ja ich hab ja sogar in vielen
kleinen cut und restart of its bevor ihr
noch was abstürzt die jupiter
wie macht man dass der neue mieter yuma
und was war das kilometer und koppel
stone ich weiß ich hab mir das rezept
nicht angeschaut doch im kader
nachgeguckt
herr kollege ja eigentlich ist dass das
rezept hier gehe ich bin gleich wieder
da war das rezept für sandstein ist auch
dass graf da will bitte aus dem
kinderland abgeholt werden okay gut 16
so ich habe einen stack sandstein das
liegt da wunderbar danke
wie mache ich das jetzt noch mal zu
dings ich glaube einfach nur neben ein
medium stein legen
du hast noch mehr mini um stein du
blödmann sekunden eine sekunde schnell
wieder gibt's mehr denn bevor z ich
komme einfach gar nicht mehr wieder rauf
nie wieder eine ganze fackeln weg man
man man komme wo bleibst du alter der
truppe stimmt also der will einfach nur
beim mini umstellen wollten
herr wiese steht beim ihren kuchen love
& peace von container
ich habe aber nicht wieder worte worte
worte anmelden so da bin ich wieder so
okay und ich habe videos schon gemeint
hast auch ein minimum stein richtig
möchtest du das machen ja nie was kommt
ich geb dir erkennen
vielleicht kommt ja bestimmt eigentlich
diamanten raus wir finden hier neue
rezepte die eigentlich gar nicht möglich
sein soll
du guckst bei mir in die richtung da
hinten ja tue ich auch der sandstein kam
aus noch völlig andere richtung zur
komcom schätzt hier hinein viel sand
soda sollte kraft
mal schauen ich hoffe doch mal dann sein
dass die hier auf seine plattform
umgebaut haben jetzt will ich mal
gespannt
ok oh mein gott oh mein gott ist das
heft die halter geht ab das ist tricky
sage ich mir ich will einfach alles
zusammen geile paar brocken fans aller
träume zerstreiten ja ob ich auch nicht
höher mit einem jetpack da muss man sich
zum rest hoch bauen mache ich mir was
ich hier nicht alles tue ich fühle mich
gerade wirklich wie sozialarbeiter der
hier wirklich gerade die aus der not
hilft und ich flieg durch den ganzen
land durch
ja stimmt höher kommt man echt nicht die
haben wirklich noch so eine blöde haben
die alles durchgeplant
was ich wohl noch ein paar fakten nicht
an unternehmen stelle ich genug sand
oder sand wird knapp warte ich leider
noch ein paar fackeln hinspiel kurz
solche hochfliegend ihr noch ein
bisschen sand geben
denni passt schon glaube ich hervorgeht
dass nichtachtung kaka aber ich was
falsch gemacht was falsch gemacht von
der firma richtig so jetzt aber solltest
du befinde ball fackeln kommt da schon
der sand geflogen ja da
moskau erwarte ich probiert mein bestes
ihren weist der ewigkeit haben die noch
einen turm gebaut
nein zum glück nicht mehr das war's das
ding ist ich muss gleich im runterfallen
die verschiedenen stones alle ersetzen
bei dir habe ich auch nein nein ich
wollte runtergedrückt vom sand online du
scheiße alter ist es blöd schon gesehen
ich bin nicht so fertig da ist es
unglaublich ich kann nicht hier sand
hatte dankeschön alter was mache ich
denn da jetzt mal ich schaue jetzt erst
mal ob ich mein aussehen wie weiter
du kannst dich damit dem koppel wieder
da so hoch bauen träum weiter
nein ich schaue was ich dann machen wir
das ist ja unsere soziale folge
das heißt ich mache jetzt auch was
sozial ist bei dir was willst du denn
was ich mache bei dir ja er diesen
kaufen von revier in meinem haus
entfernt
ok mache ich und meine glasscheiben
wieder einbauen
deine glasscheiben ja hast du
glasscheiben ja sie hat nämlich mehr wie
kaputt gehauen
er hat gesagt hat gelüftet heute auch
noch mal bei ihm gemacht aber
nun gut wenn man hier auf einem
trampolin geht cooles trampolin macht ja
megaspaß ehrt gelüftet da scheinen
sandhaufen das ist kein sand oder das
soll cent es ist richtig ich habe auch
glaube ich kack aufn sack kaufen
ja da sind ja nicht annähernd natürlich
natürlich aber ich brauche mir sind noch
1 tag
du hast doch gar keine glasscheiben bei
dobay schreiben auch nicht an dem
deutlich alles so wörtlich kraft hält
schon schnauze jetzt schon so seid ihr
ist gleich alles wieder voll mit glas so
schön danke bei mir ist dann hoffentlich
auch die kacke da oben weg da ja ich
brauche ein bisschen sand noch und dann
hab ich's ja weil ich unten liegt der
sache das ist ja göttlich so apel
was ist dass das wasser in hin zum
schweben bringt ich kann er ja mit
meiner portal gun hoch
das noch da vorne